You did it New Horizons!
It took 9 and a half years but you made it
all the way to Pluto!
No, wait, where are you going???
Hey explorers, Julian here for DNews.
NASA’s New Horizons space probe passed Pluto
in July of 2015 and with that, completed its
primary objective.
So now what?
Well you’ve got a 700 million dollar space
probe that still works and it’s whizzing
through an area of our solar system we don’t
know much about called the Kuiper belt.
Might as well do some bonus science while
it’s there right?
And that’s exactly the plan.
New Horizons will fly by a Kuiper Belt Object
named 2014 MU69 to study the ancient space
rock in more detail than would ever be possible
from Earth.
It could teach us more about the Kuiper Belt,
or the origins of our solar system.
But we’ll have to wait a little bit for
the groundbreaking data, as New Horizons won’t
reach it until January 2019, a full 13 years
after the probe was launched.
But this long lifespan is pretty run of the
mill for NASA spacecraft.
In fact, they’ve repeatedly launched probes
that have worked for more than a decade.
The pioneer missions had extremely long life.
Pioneer 6 was launched in 1965 and it’s
possibly still working.
We haven’t tried to contact it since December
of 2000, just waking it up briefly to wish
it a happy 35th birthday.
Pioneer 10 lasted 30 years before contact
was ultimately lost in 2003.
It was still sending signals from the edge
of the solar system 6 years after its planned
mission end, and technically it could still
be useful to humanity.
Pioneer 10 and 11 were the first probes to
escape the solar system, so they have on board
the famous map to earth and depictions of
the human form in case they were picked up
by intelligent life.
That’s right, given our first chance to
contact aliens we sent them nudes and directions
to our house.
Good to see nothing’s changed.
NASA’s longest lasting missions are Voyagers
1 and 2.
Voyager 1 is farther away but Voyager 2 was
actually launched first, almost 39 years ago.
The reason these spacecraft can outlive their
expected mission time is because they’re
over engineered, rigorously planned, and sometimes
a little lucky.
Pioneer 6 was equipped with a backup transmitter
that came in handy when the first failed after
30 years of use.
New Horizons can check out Kuiper Belt objects
because it was launched with extra fuel on
board.
The target selected was ultimately chosen
because it would use the least amount of fuel
to get there.
The paths the Voyager probes took were narrowed
down from 10,000 possible trajectories.
That is the definition of rigorously planned.
And we can still hear back from them because
advancements in receiver technology let us
pick up their transmissions, even though they’re
a billionth of a billionth of a watt by the
time they reach us.
For the Voyager spacecraft one of the hardest
challenges to overcome now is the fact that
most of the original engineers are retired,
or even deceased.
The probes have outlived their creators, and
still NASA expects them to work for another
decade
And it’s not just space probes that are
outlasting expectations.
The Mars rovers are doing surprisingly well.
Opportunity, which landed on mars 12 years
ago, is still on the Red Planet grinding up
rocks for science.
The plucky solar powered bot has stayed alive
almost 48 times the length of its warranty
thanks to smart placement that kept it in
the sun during winter.
See, these NASA guys are smart!
It’s sister rover, Spirit, perished when
it got stuck in soft soil in 2009 and a shadow
crept over it.
So to recap, is dead, and they’re making
the most of Opportunity.
NASA is great at squeezing as much life out
of their missions as possible.
They even come up with clever ways to learn
things from a mission’s death.
To learn why NASA would intentionally crash
a satellite into the moon, check out Trace’s
video here,
Of course all these probes are unmanned, but
one day maybe they won’t be.
Could you make it 40 years alone in space
if it meant taking humanity to a new frontier?
Let us know in the comments, subscribe for
more, and I’ll see you next time on DNews.